the hottest day of the year in santiago
chile on average is january 7th when the
average high temperature is 29 degrees
celsius the coolest day of the year has
an average high temperature 14 degrees
celsius
use a trigonometric function to model
the temperature in santiago chile using
365 days as the length of a year
remember that january 7th is the summer
in santiago how many days after january
7th is the first spring day
when the temperature reaches 20 degrees
celsius so let's do this in first parts
in two parts so first let's let's use a
trigonometric let's try to figure out a
trigonometric function that models the
temperature in santiago chile so we'll
have temperature as a function of days
where days are the number where days are
the number of days after january 7th and
once we have that trigonometric function
to model that then we can answer the
second part i guess the essential
question which is how many days after
january 7th is the first spring day when
the temperature reaches 20 degrees
celsius
so to think about this let's graph it
let's graph it and it should become
pretty apparent why they are suggesting
that we use a trigonometric function to
model this because our seasonal
variations they're cyclical they go up
and down and actually if you look at the
average temperature for any city over
the course of the year it really does
look like a trigonometric function
so let's
so let's this axis right over here this
is the passage of the days let's do d
for days and that's going to be in days
after january 7th so this right over
here would be january 7th
and
the horse and the vertical axis this is
the horizontal line the vertical axis is
going to be in terms of
celsius degrees
so
this let's see the high is 29
and i could write 29 degrees celsius and
then or that the highest average day
and then if this is 0 then 14 which is
the lowest average day
14 degrees celsius and so our
temperature will vary between these two
extremes our temperature is going to
vary but the highest average day which
they already told us is january 7th we
get to 29 degrees celsius and then the
coldest day of the year on average you
get to you get to an average high of 14
degrees celsius
so it looks
like this we're talking about average
highs on a given day
and the reason why it's why a
trigonometric function is a good idea is
because it's cyclical so this is january
7th if you go 365 days in the future
you're back at three you're back at
january 7th so this is the if the
average high temperature is 29 degrees
celsius on that day the average high
temperature is going to be 29 degrees
celsius on that day
now we're using a trigonometric function
so we're going to hit our low point
exactly halfway in between
something right like that
and so our function is going to look
like this our function so let me see let
me just draw the low point
right over there and this is a high
point
it's a high point right over there
that looks pretty good
and then i have the high point right
over here and then i just need to
connect them and there you go i've drawn
one period of our trigonometric function
and our period is 365 days if we go 365
days later we're at the same point in
the cycle we are at the same point in
the year we're at the same point in the
year
so what i want you to do right now is
given what i've just drawn try to model
this right so this is this right over
here is let's write this this is capital
t as a function of d
try to figure out an expression for
capital t as a function of d and
remember it's going to be some
trigonometric function
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
and you might say well this could look
like a cosine curve maybe it could be a
sine curve which one should i use you
could actually use either one but i
always like to go with the simpler one
they just think about well if this was
if these were angles either
actually degrees or radians which
trigonometric function starts at your
maximum point
well cosine of 0 is 1. the cosine starts
at your maximum point sine of 0 is 0. so
i'm going to use cosine here
i'm going to use a cosine function
so
temperature as a function of days is
going to be some amplitude times our
cosine function
and we're going to have some argument to
our cosine function and then i'm
probably going to have to shift it so
let's think about how we would do that
well what's the midline here well the
midline's the halfway point between our
high and our low so our middle point if
we were to visualize it
looks just like
so that is our midline
right over there
and what value is this well what's the
average of 29 and 14 29 plus 14 is 43
divided by 2 is 21.5
degrees celsius so that's our midline so
essentially we've shifted up our
function by
we've shifted up our function by that
amount if we just had a regular cosine
function our midline would be at zero
but now we're at 21.5 degrees celsius so
i'll just write plus
21.5 that's how much we've shifted it up
now what's the amplitude
well our amplitude is how much we
diverge from the midline so over here
we're 7.5
above the midline so that's plus 7.5
here we're 7.5 below the midline
so minus 7.5 so our amplitude is 7.5 our
maximum va the maximum amount we go away
from the midline is 7.5
so that's our amplitude
and now let's think about our argument
to the cosine function right over here
so we're going to have our it's going to
be a function of the days
and what do we want when when 365 days
have gone by we want our cosine we want
this entire argument to do be 2 pi so
when d is 365 we want this whole thing
about to evaluate to 2 pi
so we could put 2 pi
over 365
in here and you probably you might
remember your formulas i always forget
them that's why i always try to reason
through them again the formula is oh you
want 2 pi divided by your period and all
the rest but i just like to think okay
look after one period which is 365 days
i want the whole argument over here to
be 2 pi i wanted i want to go around the
unit circle once and so if this is 365
if this is 2 pi over 365 when you
multiply by 365 your argument here is
going to be 2 pi
so just like that we've done the first
part of this question